All right, we've covered quite
a bit of ground already.
We've heard a lot about
what accessibility is and
why it matters for everyone.
We heard about some different
types of impairments and
what we might need to think about.
We saw what it's like to
use a screen reader and
we took a quick look at WCAG and
the WebAIM accessibility checklist.
>> For the rest of the course we're
going to dive into the practicalities of
actually creating accessible websites.
That's right we're not going
to just talk at you for
the whole course, you're going to
actually create some accessible code.
>> Yeah, so we're going to organize
this around three main topics, focus and
keyboard, looking at how to make sure
that we build things which can be
operated with a keyboard.
This is important for
users with motor impairments but also
ensures that your UI is in a good shape
for the next topic which is semantics.
Semantics is where we make sure that
we're expressing our interface in
a robust way which works with
a variety of assistive technology.
And finally styling and visual design.
Look at some techniques for making
sure the visual UI is as flexible and
usable as possible.
>> Now each of those
topics could probably fill
a whole course by themselves.
So we're not going to be able to
cover every single aspect of creating
accessible websites.
However, we're going to give you
enough information to get started and
point you at some good places
to learn more about each topic.
I'm sure you're all eager to get started
so let's begin with a look at how and
why you need to think about
focus in your web application.